alors qu'est ce que vous diriez d'aller
à la montagne pour les vacances de noël
avec grèce elle aimerait vraiment
apprendre à vous connaître
c'est le bonheur notre maire excusé bon
ça va je veux pas te laisser seuls avec
les enfants si je pense que c'est au
dessus de mes forces
non ça va aller c'était mon idée et
c'est juste pour deux ou trois jours je
peux gérer
ok j'y vais
amusez vous bien
c'est quoi ça regardez grèce tous les
membres sont suicidés souffre elle
repentez vous et vous trouverez le salut
les enfants et un truc pas net entre
nous et on est coincé ici tous les trois
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe le plus de
courant ont sont mes affaires c'est du
délire quoi certains tue quelque chose
repens toi repens toi de tes péchés il
ya quelqu'un c'est vous qui avez fait ça
on n'a rien fait du tout un ça va
qu'est ce que tu racontes regard d'or
ont dépensé ici
seigneur chien c'est plié
[Musique]
travail
fais moi confiance
vous n'avez aucune raison d'avoir peur